المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
(موسيقى)
شكرا على
حتى أتكلم اليوم ب TEDx جامعة القدس
طلبوا مني أن أتكلم، فكرت في الموضوع
الذي سوف أتكلم عنه ، وكنت
أعطي إنطباعي على السنين التي قضيتها مع
الطلاب بمجال التعليم تقريباً تسعة عشر سنة
بعلم في جامعة القدس
و أكثر شيء أراه مع
الطلاب الذين  افتخر أنني قريب منهم
هو موضوع الارتباك المستمر الذي ألاحظه عند
الشبان والشابات
يأتوني الشبان والشابات
لا يعرفون ماذا يريدون أو ماهي اهدافهم
غير متأكدين من التخصص الذي دخلوه
يشعرون بالارتباك
فقررت اليوم ان اختار بالتحديد هذا الموضوع
موضوع الوضوح وأهمية الوضوح للشخص
على أساس أنه ينفذ قراراته
ويأخذ القرار الصائب له
و للشخصية الخاص به
وكل هذا قد تم دراسته بواسطة العلم
العلم يقول لنا
إذا الشخص يرى في حياته أنه
ليس لديه أي خيار
معناه إذاً أن حالته النفسية سلبية
إذا الشخص كان في حاله تجعله يشعر أن ليس
لديه خيارات
يكون الشخص لا يشعر أن حياته على ما يرام
وهذا شيء غير رائع ونحن نراه هنا في بلادنا
يأتي الطلاب ويتذمرون بشأن الظروف
يقولون هذا المكان يخنقنا ، لا توجد فرص
مرة أخرى مشاعر سلبية
على الجانب الآخر، هناك أناس يواجهون
الكثير من الخيارات
وعندما يكون هناك كثير من الخيارات
يصبح هناك كثير من الارتباك
ماذا أختار؟
هذا أو هذا
وهناك الفئة في المكان الصحيح في الأعلى
الفئة التي يكون لديها خيارات واضحة
تريد الاختيار منها
إذا كان لديك خيارات قليلة
وهذه الخيارات محددة بناءً على رغبتك
أو الشيء المهم لك
حينها يكون الاختيار
أسهل وعندها نشعر بطاقة إيجابية
الشيء الذي يحدث بالحياة هو
إن الحياة تقدم لنا كثير من الخيارات
اختيارات نقوم بها و قرارات صغيرة
نتخذها في بداية حياتنا
يكون لها تأثير كبير فيما بعد
وجميعنا نمر بهذه القرارات
امممممم يعني
قرارات حاسمة
أدبي أو علمي؟ ماذا أدرس؟
أي جامعة ارتاد؟
كيف أختار شريكي في الحياة؟
و كل هذه الأشياء المهمة في حياتنا
هناك عملية يمكننا القيام بها
إذا أردنا أن نتخذ القرار السليم
العملية هذه هي
أن يكون الشخص صادقاً مع نفسه
أنا أقول دائماً
أن أهم وقت في نهاري هو
الصبح عندما أدخل إلى الحمام وأغلق الباب
انفرد بنفسي وأنظر للمرآة
ليس فقط على شكلي أو شعري
أو ملابسي إذا كانت ملائمة
لا ، أنظر للمرآة
بعمق إلى روحي وأسأل نفسي
هل أنا سعيد بحياتي؟
هل أنا سعيد بخياراتي؟
إذا كان الجواب نعم فهذا جميل
معناه انني اعمل الاشياء المريحة والمهمة لي
اذا الجواب لا
إذن هناك حاجة للتغيير
إذا كنت صادق مع نفسك
تحدث مع المرآة
وحددت الأشياء المهمة في حياتك
الأشياء التي تجعلني سعيد
وهذا الكلام موجه بشكل شخصي
لأن الشيء الذي يسعدني يختلف عن الشيء الذي
يسعد شخص آخر
لذلك
كل شخص لابد أن يكون صادق مع نفسه
ويختار الأشياء التي تشعره بالسعادة
عندما تكون صادق مع نفسك
وتعرف الاشياء المهمة لك
ليس لي أو لوالدك أو أخاك
أو ماذا سيقول عنك الآخرين
حينها الاختيارات اللي تكلمت عنها  سابقاً
يصبح إتخاذها أسهل
لأنه انت تكون سألت نفسك
ماهو المهم بالنسبة لك قبل
أن تنفذ قرارك
الآن سوف أخبركم بقصة شخصية حصلت معي
وكانت واحدة من القرارات
التي اتخذتها في حياتي عندما كنت في أمريكا
كنت في أمريكا
كنت ناجح في أمريكا
كنت أعمل مع أكبر شركات العالم ب
Orinda division ، كنت أعمل مع شركة فايزر
كان عندي بيت ملك، كنت متزوج وعندي أطفال
والحياة كانت رائعة وكان يجب أن أكون سعيد
لكن عندما انفردت بنفسي وتأملت وجدت
إنه انا لست سعيد
انا لست سعيد !
لماذا أنا لست سعيد ؟ وجائت لحظة الصدق
لأن كل هذه الاشياء: البيت والعمل والمال
ليس هذا ما يجعلني سعيد
الذي يسعدني والذي أريده، والمهم بالنسبة لي
هو ان اكون هنا في بلادي
بين اهلي وأقاربي
أن أعيش مع أمي وأبي وأكون بجانبهم
أن أرى أولادي يكبروا وسط عائلتهم
هذا كان المهم بالنسبة لي .
نعم انا أعرف ناس كثير استقروا في امريكا
ويعيشوا بسعادة هناك، لن انتقدهم
هذا جميل ، أنا سعيد من أجلهم
ولكن البقاء هناك لم ينجح بالنسبة لي
لم يجعلني أشعر بالسعادة
وهذه هي الرسالة التي أريد إيصالها لكم
لا تتخذ قراراتك ووفقاً للآخرين
كن صادقاً مع نفسك واختار القرارات التي
تجعلك أنت سعيد
الشيء المهم بالنسبة لك
إذن ، الخطوة التالية، اللحظة التي تتخذ
فيها القرار
لا تنظر للخلف
أقابل الكثير من الأشخاص كانوا في أمريكا
أو السعودية أو دبي
وأخذوا القرار الرجوع
عندما يصلون إلى بلدانهم
يشعرون بالندم
وهذا غير جيد
عندما تتخذ قرار لا تندم عليه
لأنك اذا فعلت هذا
ستعيش حياتك بتعاسة
لذلك، دائماً تطلع للمستقبل
وابحث عن الفرص المتاحة
اذا اتخذت قرار إلتزم به
الشيء الآخر الذي لاحظته
وهذه رسالة مني للجميع
أنه يا أصدقائي
نعم رجعت لهنا
ومن أهم الأشياء التي تجعلني سعيد هو
أن أكون قادر على إحداث تغيير
بعودتي لجامعة القدس
والذي أعتبره اهم إنجاز لي
هو القدرة على عمل فرق في حياة تلاميذي
القدرة على التأثير والمساهمة
القدرة على تعليمهم
إن الطلاب الذين يمرون بي ببداية
السنة الثالثة عندما ينتهون منها
يصبحون أشخاص مختلفين
لذلك، بالنسبة لي كانت هذه طريقتي
في إحداث تغيير
سؤالي لكم كيف وجودكم يحدث فارق
كيف أنتم سوف تحدثون اختلاف؟
أياً كان القرار الذي سوف تتخذونه
كل فرد منكم يجب أن ينظر للمرآة ويسأل نفسه
كيف سوف أحدث تغيير؟
إذا كل فرد عمل حتى يحدث تغيير
يعمل حتى يغير البيئة الذي يعيش فيها
إذا أنا غيرت للأفضل وانت غيرت للأفضل
كلنا سوف نساهم في تقدمنا
وتقدم مجتمعنا
وتتقدم بلادنا
والله يعلم أن كثير من الاشياء
التي يجب أن تتحسن
نعم
الآن
الأمر الآخر الذي أريد التحدث عنه
هو أنه هناك الكثير من الأشياء
التي من الممكن أن تضيع وقتنا
تشتت تركيزنا عن الأشياء المهمة بالنسبة لنا
التلفاز و مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وهذا طبيعي في الحياة المعاصرة
لكن المشكلة التي أراها أنها أصبحت موضع هوس
أرجو أن تحذر منها
لأنها سوف تشتتك عن الاشياء المهمة
سوف تضيع تركيزك على تنفيذ مهمتك
آخر شيء سوف أذكر فقط مثال على أمر ممرت به
سأخبرك بذلك مرة آخرى ، كن صادقاً مع نفسك
كن واضحاً مع نفسك
حول الشيء المهم بالنسبة لك
من اللحظة التي عدت بها إلى مدينتي
الجميع يخبرني أنه يجب ان أفتح مشروع تجاري
الآن أنا أمام قرار مهم مرة آخرى
كان يجب أن أكون صادقاً مع نفسي
هل أنا من الأشخاص الذين يمتلكون عقلية
المخاطرة و أفكار المشاريع التجارية
وكل هذه الأشياء
أم انا من نوعية الأشخاص
الذين يميلون للأبحاث والمعارف
الوضوح الذي أملكه
جعلني أدرك اني من الفئة الثانية
أنا شخص لا يمتلك عقلية تجارية
أنا أميل للاكتشاف والمعرفة والتعليم
هذا ما يجعلني أشعر بالسعادة
هذا ما نجح معي
هذا هو المجال الذي ابدعت به
لا أستطيع الا الشعور بالتقدير تجاه الاشخاص
ذو العقلية التجارية
ويريدون فتح المشاريع التجارية
أكن لهم كل الاحترام
لكن ليس أنا
ولأنني أعرف ذاتي
وأعرف ماهو المهم بالنسبة لي
وأعرف الشيء الذي أمتاز به
اذاً يجب أن أتخذ القرار الصائب
الذي يصلح لي
أريد أن أختم لكم اليوم بقصة
سمعتها منذ وقت طويل ولكن
علقت في ذهني
وهذه القصة تتحدث عن مسابقة جري
شخص يجب أن ينتقل من منطقة إلى
منطقة بأسرع وقت ممكن
لكن المسابقة وسط الثلوج
وهناك شرطين للفوز
أن تجري بأسرع وقت ممكن
وتمشي في خط مستقيم
الجميع تعب في السباق إلا شخص واحد
استطاع الوصول لخط النهاية بوقت قياسي
عندما سألوه سر نجاحه أجابهم
أن سر نجاحه هو أنه ركز بصره على الهدف
وركض باتجاهه
لم أقلق بشأن كوني أجري بخط مستقيم أم لا
لأنني ركزت على الهدف
الخط بشكل تلقائي أصبح مستقيم
أما الأشخاص الآخرين كانوا ينظرون
للخلف بشكل مستمر ليتاكدوا
إذا كانوا يجرون بخط مستقيم أم لا
والعبرة التي أريد إيصالها هي
اختار هدفك واعمل بجد للوصول إليه
اجر نحوه
ولا تنظر ابداً للخلف
شكراً لكم